that in Trump says the nation is making
a lot of progress in its battle at the
coronavirus mr. Trump kept his remarks
brief on Friday allowing Vice President
Mike Pence to take the lead in the
administration's response the president
is scrapping a planned trip to New
Jersey this weekend after signing off on
a new executive order to protect US
monuments
Nikole Killion is at the White House
this morning Nicole good morning any
details about why the president canceled
this trip
well Michelle the White House says it
has nothing to do with New Jersey's new
quarantine restrictions while the
president tweeted he wanted to stay here
to quote make sure law and order is
enforced protesters in the nation's
capitol Friday demanded the removal of
the emancipation memorial depicting
President Abraham Lincoln standing over
a freed slave after crowds tried to take
down a statue of President Andrew
Jackson near the White House this week
President Trump issued an executive
order it declares anyone who vandalizes
or destroys a monument Memorial or
statute should be prosecuted to the
fullest extent of the law using existing
penalties of up to ten years in prison
and it warned state and local agencies
that fail to protect monuments could
lose federal support when the president
appeared to threaten demonstrators last
month with phrases like when the looting
starts the shooting start Facebook
encountered a backlash including a
growing boycott from advertisers but now
the social media giant says it will flag
posts that violate its policies if we
determine the content may lead to
violence or deprive people of their
right to vote we're going to take that
content down no matter who says it yeah
but we have a little work to do and
we'll get
the president did not participate in a
coronavirus taskforce briefing Friday
one week since his first campaign rally
in Oklahoma CBS News has learned Trump
staffers were told in an email Friday
night they will be required to obtain a
negative code 19 test this weekend
before returning to work dozens have
been quarantined since the event the
vice president defended the president's
actions freedom of speech and the right
to peaceably assemble is enshrined in
the Constitution of the United States
and even in a health crisis the American
people don't forfeit our constitutional
rights a local reporter who covered the
rally now says he has tested positive
for kovat 19 he says he was in the arena
for a few hours wore a mask and followed
social distancing rules but and at the
dimmi ologist told him it's difficult to
determine when he contracted the virus
Jeff okay Nicole thank you very much